Netflix October lineup is bursting with
gory goodness to usher in Halloween but
the streaming workhorse isn't a
one-trick pony
so you can also fill up on brand-new
comedy action drama and new seasons of
your favorite TV shows including the
hotly anticipated stranger things season
2 here's everything coming to Netflix in
October 2017 Rodney Carrington here
comes the truth musician comedian Rodney
Carrington has made a name for himself
through his crude stand-up infused with
country music ballets and he's been
touring again in summer 2017 with his
brand new routine here comes the truth
if you haven't been able to see
Carrington show live it's coming as a
Netflix exclusive on October 3rd the
bonus family season 1 this popular
Swedish series was earmarked for global
distribution by Netflix in early 2017
and rebranded as a Netflix original
everywhere outside of Sweden marking
another fantastic foreign acquisition
that let's be honest nobody else would
have ever heard of not for the streaming
service this dramedy series centers on
four divorcees who find new spouses and
new stepchildren only in sweden
stepmothers and stepfathers are actually
called bonus moms and bonus dads Netflix
picked up distribution rights for the
first two seasons so while only the
first season is dropping on October 5th
chances are you'll be able to find the
second season on Netflix sometime soon
afterward the death and life of Marsha P
Johnson for those who don't know Marsha
P Johnson was an activist and
transgender woman who was an
instrumental figure in the gay rights
movement for decades on July 6 1992 her
body was found floating in the Hudson
River sparking one of the most hotly
debated investigations in recent history
although police initially ruled
Johnson's death a suicide public outcry
and a steadily mounting pile of evidence
forced police to reopen her case in 2012
to determine if she had in reality been
murdered and dumped in the river the new
Netflix documentary the death and life
of Marsha P Johnson takes a hard look at
that investigation and the circumstances
leading up to Johnson's untimely death
queued up on October 6th sabores season
1 this crime thriller marks Netflix
first italian-language original series
but don't let the subtitles hold you
back this series looks to be packed with
criminal intrigue political corruption
and all the dirty laundry you'd expect
from a mob story set in the heart of
the series will serve as a prequel to
the 2015 film of the same name and if
it's anywhere near as good as that movie
Saburo may become a modern crime classic
plus because it's a prequel it's a safe
bet that viewers will be able to jump in
even if they haven't seen the movie the
first season drops October 6 Cristina P
mother inferior comedian christina
pazsitzky has been making waves in the
stand-up scene lately
although she's still probably best known
for her podcast your mom's house
hopefully her Netflix stand-up special
mother inferior which premieres in
October 10th will change that and
introduce Pichette ski to a wider
audience Fey dayit Aris October seems to
be the month of foreign language
originals in addition to Savera Netflix
is premiering Veda at Aris a Spanish
comedy film about an unlikely group of
people stuck in an apartment waiting for
a mysterious phone call
that's about as vague of a premise as
you're likely to find but if you're in
the mood for something a little outside
the box you can queue up fay-ta' at Aris
when it hits Netflix worldwide on
October 12 kingdom of us take a step
inside small-town America with kingdom
of us a poignant documentary chronicling
the shattered lives of seven siblings
whose world was torn apart when their
father committed suicide through candid
interviews and home videos kingdom of us
pieces together the bond this family
shared with their father and the long
road ahead of them as they tried to deal
with the tragedy of his loss it's
guaranteed to be an emotional painful
ride but there may just be hope on the
horizon experience all the highs and
lows alongside the Shanks family on
October 13 mine hunters season one from
creator Joe Penhall mine hunter is an
all-new Netflix original that follows
FBI profiler Holden Ford played by
Jonathan Groff as he gets inside the
heads of serial killers to bring them to
justice
the series premiere is directed by David
Fincher virtually ensuring a dark
twisted kick-off to a series that dives
into the minds of the most notorious
psychopaths of the 20th century Holt
McElhaney infringes Anna Torv co-star
get ready to binge on the insanity when
the first season hits on October 13
Voltron legendary defenders season 4
just two months after season 3 hit
Netflix the streaming service is
bringing in the fourth season of its hit
animated series Voltron legendary
defender the same cast returns to voice
the colorful paladins of Voltron and the
season 4 picks up right where the third
left off with a team of heroes working
to stop their nemesis evil plan check in
for more the fast paced action on
October 13th the Meyerowitz stories so
far Adam Sandler's Netflix films haven't
done much to impress either critics or
audiences that streak may end with the
Meyerowitz stories which sees Sandler
headlining once again with a supporting
cast that includes Dustin Hoffman and
Ben Stiller to name a few with writer
director Noah Baumbach up the squid in
the whale at the helm we're hoping this
installment and the Sandler verse will
play the laughs more low-key than some
of Sandler's previous films and deliver
a compelling story at the same time so
far early critical response has been
overwhelmingly favorable check it out on
October 13th the babysitter Netflix
original horror comedy the babysitter
follows a twelve-year-old boy named Cole
finds out that is super hot babysitter
happens to be a satanic killer and now
that Cole knows her secret he'll have to
kill or be killed to survive the night
directed by McGee from a script by Brian
Duffield the babysitter premieres on
Friday October 13th
Patton Oswalt Annihilation you've got to
love Patton Oswalt in the affable every
man is back in October 17th with a new 1
hour stand-up special in annihilation
Oswalt gets more personal than ever
before as he works the pain and loss of
his wife's recent passing into a new
intimate stand-up set if you want to see
Patton Oswalt as you've never seen him
tune in for annihilation and be prepared
for both laughs and tears along the way
the day I met al Chapo the kate del
Castillo story told us a three-part
miniseries the day I met old chapo
chronicles the fateful interview between
one of history's most vicious drug lords
and a list Mexican actress kate del
Castillo Castillo will star in the
series as well as produce and the
documentary will draw from real-life
footage of the meeting and the planning
in the days and weeks leading up to the
interview with the cartel kingpin get a
closer look at the true story on October
20th wheelman strap in for high-stakes
action and an adrenaline-filled thrill
ride
when wheelman drops on Netflix on
October 20th starring Frank Grillo as
the wheelman in the title the story
centers on a driver for a band of bank
robbers who gets double-crossed on a job
with the lives of his family at stake
he'll stop at nothing to find the truth
and bring the backstabber to justice
it's kill or be killed
and hopefully this feature film debut
from writers Rhett
Jeremie rush will deliver all the
pulse-pounding action promised in the
wheelman trailer 1922 between his castle
rock series miss series The Dark Tower
Netflix Gerald's game and oh yeah it
Stephen King is experiencing a
big-screen resurgence in a big way
kinks next story to hit Netflix is 1922
starring Thomas Jane is a rancher in the
early 20th century who convinces his son
to help him murder his wife if the film
takes the same cues as a source novel
1922 will hopefully turn out to be a
tense thriller fuse with paranoia of the
worst kind
check it out on October 20th haters back
off season 2 based on a YouTube channel
called Miranda sings created by colleen
ballinger
haters back off as a satirical look at
YouTube fame and everyone who wants a
piece of that pie with or without any
discernible talent this Netflix original
first hit the streaming service in 2016
and stars Ballinger in a continuation of
her youtube persona Miranda sings a
self-centered eccentric girl who thinks
she's good at everything when she really
isn't look for season 2 in October 20th
one of us this documentary certainly
comes with an interesting premise it's
about three Hasidic Jews living in a
strict religious community in New York
who decide to leave that world behind
abandoning everything they've ever known
they face hate and violence from both
the outside world and their former
community one of us promises to be a
slicing portrait of religious
intolerance and the struggle to live
with all the cards stacked against you
look for it on October 20th Joan Didion
the center will not hold novelists
journalists and screenwriter Joan Didion
became the voice of the counterculture
through her stories and essays published
throughout the 60s and 70s all the way
up to the present day the documentary
the center will not hold travels back in
time across Didion's extraordinary life
to explore how a young writer became a
pop culture icon and literary legend
take the ride on October 27 stranger
things season 2 after a groundbreaking
first season followed by a painful
year-long wait stranger things is
finally back with season 2 and things
promise to get even hairier in the
upside-down this time around executive
producer Shawn Levy told Variety that
the stakes are even higher in our next
visit to the town of Hawkins as if we
needed any more incentive to tune in
when stranger things season 2
cops October 27th Judah Friedlander
America is the greatest country in the
United States with his deadpan delivery
ironic punchlines and big shaggy beard
Judah Friedlander is definitely a unique
face in the stand-up world although most
people likely know him best from his
role as Frank in 30 rock
Friedlander's new stand-up special
America is the greatest country in the
United States takes a stab at the
American Way of life I am putting
everything from racism to foreign policy
according to Friedlander the special
will premiere on Netflix on October 31st
although Netflix maintains that it will
air on the 30th either way it'll arrive
just in time to help you ease those
late-night jitters after all those
horror movies you'll probably be
watching this month new movies it
wouldn't be a proper October without a
new lineup of horror and thriller movies
and Netflix is bringing in some
brand-new shockers like 13 demons the
survivalist and cult of Chucky out
October 3rd followed by 2017 s cannibal
thriller raw the day after for more
down-to-earth thrills this month is
seeing the edition of Blood Diamond and
Stanley Kubrick's Eyes Wide Shut both of
which arrive October 1st
additionally Donnie Darko arrives
October 11th and Quentin Tarantino's the
hateful eight is shooting for an October
25th premiere for more casual viewing
look for the addition of several called
classic comedies like 1996's don't be a
menace to South Central while drinking
your juice in the hood on top of that
Netflix is bringing in Eagle versus
shark an offbeat indie comedy directed
by Taika Waititi and starring Jemaine
Clement the same comedic duo who brought
us what we do in the shadows both films
arrive October 1st along with I Love You
Man Tommy Boy and both Miss Congeniality
movies Netflix documentary Game has been
off the charts lately and October is set
to continue that trend an October first
look for generation iron ice guardians
and Tokyo idols later in the month get
your music fix with back-to-back biopics
mr. dynamite the rise of James Brown and
Chris Brown welcome to my life
premiering on October 2nd and 7th
respectively
finally what's Halloween without family
time for the younger generation of
trick-or-treaters Netflix is bringing on
such family fare as a Cinderella story
once upon a song Charlie and the
Chocolate Factory and 2017
verse the lost village to name a few new
television stranger things may be the
highlight of netflix new series but that
doesn't mean there won't be plenty of
other news shows and seasons to binge in
the coming month highlights include
season two of clever man on October
first season three of shits Creek on
October 5th and the first season of a
serial adaptation of Stephen King's the
mist on October 24th which follows new
characters caught in the same mysterious
mist that terrorized the cast of the
2007 film also arriving on October 24th
are the first two seasons of wanted the
acclaimed Australian drama series about
two strangers who find themselves drawn
together during a murder investigation
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]